[Music]
as kanye west continues to launch public
attacks against his estranged wife kim
kardashian and her boyfriend pete
davidson a source tells et how the 41
year old reality star is handling it all
specifically how she feels about pete
coming to her defense i'm just rolling
with it just in case you missed the
drama let me get you up to speed
over the past few weeks the former
couple has been publicly feuding on
social media with yay hurling a series
of accusations at kim on instagram and
trashing her new beau both online and in
song god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
yeah the music video for the grammy
winners track easy showed the rapper
kidnapping a claymation figure of the 28
year old comedian burying him in the
ground and decapitating him
[Music]
at the time a source told e.t pete was
taking it all with a grain of salt
adding that the saturday night live star
isn't threatened by kanye in any way
shape or form quote he is almost
flattered by it all because it is so
ridiculous to him it is what it is
and while a source previously told et
that pete was trying to ignore his rants
that seemingly changed over the weekend
when the king of staten island star's
friend and saturday night live rider
dave cyrus posted this alleged text
exchange between pete and yay after the
44 year old musician fired off a series
of posts alleging that his ex wasn't
allowing him to see their children
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
in the screenshot which has since been
deleted pete asks the rapper to calm
down and praises kim as literally the
best mother quote i've decided i'm not
gonna let you treat us this way anymore
and i'm done being quiet grow the [ __ ]
up
now a source tells e.t how kim feels
about her boyfriend confronting her ex
quote kim didn't want pete to make
things worse but she was also glad that
he stuck up for her it is nice that kim
has pete on her side publicly and
privately i love that energy in my life
the source explains that the mama 4
hopes kanye will move on and stop
attacking her and pete mainly so that
their kids won't be affected negatively
but so far that's just not been the case
in fact the source notes that their
eldest child eight-year-old north hears
things from her friends and knows how to
find her dad on social media i do have a
family that i have to just be positive
and get it together for as for pete the
source says he is really over kanye has
had enough is at a point where he is not
backing down to put it simply pete
thinks yay has gone way too far quote
pete is super into kim and this is how
he is showing it he is not taking
anything from kanye anymore it's a
different experience for sure
and kim well according to e.t source
kanye's actions are causing a lot of
stress for her and she agrees with pete
you just gotta roll with it
and if kanye doesn't stop she knows she
will be forced to take more drastic
measures quote she just doesn't want
anything bad to happen
[Music]
you